si fx es igual a x elevado a la sexta
potencia menos equis elevado al cubo
cual es el coeficiente para el término
que contienen a x + 2 elevado a la
cuarta potencia en el polinomio de
taylor df centrado en x igual a menos 2
así que como siempre hace una pequeña
pausa antes de que empecemos a trabajar
el problema juntos e intentar resolverlo
ok de manos a la obra en general un
polinomio de taylor un polinomio de
taylor p de x se ve de la siguiente
manera esto va a ser exactamente igual y
recuerda si estamos centrados en x igual
a menos 2 eso es importante entonces se
va a ver de la siguiente manera
pd x se va a ver como la función
evaluada en menos 2
esto a su vez dividido entre 0 factorial
entre 0 factorial que multiplica a x
menos el valor donde estamos centrados
que es menos 2 pero bueno x menos menos
2 es lo mismo que x + 2 x + 2 esto
elevado a la potencia 0 elevado a la
potencia 0 que al final todo esto es 1
esto es 1 y esto de aquí pero lo voy a
escribir así para que veas el patrón ya
esto le vamos a sumar ok
recuerda que es una serie una serie
infinita entonces le vamos a sumar y
ahora observa que el patrón está
creciendo vamos a tomarnos la primera
derivada de f la primera derivada de fm
y la vamos a evaluar en menos 2 en el
punto donde estamos centrados esto lo
vamos a dividir entre 1 factorial ok y
lo vamos a multiplicar por x
2 x 2 elevado a la potencia 1 ya esto le
vamos a sumar y observa el patrón la
segunda derivada la segunda derivada
evaluada en menos 2 ok esto dividido
entre 2 factorial ok que multiplican a x
+ 2 esto elevado al cuadrado y bueno
podemos seguir a esto le vamos a sumar
ok
la tercera derivada evaluada en menos 2
ok esto a su vez dividido entre 3
factorial que multiplica a x más 2
elevado al cubo ok y a esto le sumamos y
voy a seguir un término más porque
observa lo que queremos es encontrar el
término es más lo voy a poner con otro
color
el coeficiente para el término que
contiene a x + 2 elevado a la cuarta
potencia así que ya estamos al ladito
esto me quedaría más la función derivada
cuatro veces cuatro veces lo puedo
escribir así también se escribe como un
4 en un paréntesis
esta cuarta derivada evaluada en menos 2
está dividido entre 4 factorial ok que
multiplica a x + 2 esto elevado la
cuarta potencia y vamos a seguir sumando
y sumando y sumando de hecho aquí
debería decir que esto es
aproximadamente déjame ponerlo así esto
va a ser aproximadamente toda esta
expresión que tengo aquí porque todavía
nos faltan un buen de sumandos por acá
ahora bien esta es la parte que nos
interesa y bueno cuál es el coeficiente
que nosotros estamos buscando déjame
ponerlo mica así con este color voy a
poner el coeficiente que es lo que
nosotros estamos buscando
bueno pues va a ser esta parte que tengo
aquí en esta parte que tengo aquí va a
ser el coeficiente tras el cual vamos
observar aquí tenemos x + 2 elevado a la
cuarta potencia que es justo lo que
buscamos y lo que está al lado de él es
el coeficiente entonces vamos a tener
que tomarnos la cuarta derivada de esta
función que tengo aquí evaluarla en
menos dos y dividirlo entre cuatro
factorial así que hagámoslo primero me
voy a tomar las derivadas que busco si
esta es mi función
la primera derivada de mi función va a
ser igual y bueno es simplemente aplicar
la regla de las potencias aquí me
quedarían seis veces seis veces x
elevado a la quinta potencia 6 menos 15
menos 3 veces x elevado a la segunda
potencia ok
está la primera derivada voy a derivar
lo una segunda vez y me va a quedar
bueno aquí tengo un 6 por 5 eso es lo
mismo que 30 30 veces x elevado a las
cinco menos uno
4 - 2 x 36 x elevado a la potencia 2 - 1
es decir a la primera potencia ok la
tercera derivada la tercera derivada me
va a quedar me va a quedar como 4 por 30
eso es 120 120 x elevado a la tercera
potencia menos 6 es la derivada de 6x es
simplemente 6 y si cálculo la cuarta
derivada recuerda lo poco escribir así o
lo puedo escribir como la cuarta
derivada ambas son formas equivalentes
pero para seguir este mismo patrón voy a
poner aquí cuatro líneas la cuarta
derivada de x esto va a ser igual a 120
por 3 lo cual es 360 x elevado a lahm a
la segunda potencia elevado al cuadrado
y la derivada de menos 6 se va es la
derivada de una constante ok
esta es la cuarta derivada de x pero yo
quiero la cuarta derivada evaluada en
menos 2
vamos a hacerlo si veo cuál es la cuarta
derivada
evaluada en menos 2 me quedaría que esto
es lo mismo que 360 que multiplican a
menos 2 elevado al cuadrado lo cual es
exactamente igual que 360 que multiplica
a 4 y lo voy a poner así porque vamos a
dividir entre 4 factorial es decir el
valor que nosotros buscamos es
exactamente igual déjame escribirlo así
la anp cuarta derivada evaluada en menos
2 entre 4 factorial que es lo que
nosotros buscamos es exactamente igual
que 360 que multiplica a 4 esto a su vez
dividido entre 4 factorial que es 4 por
2 por 3 por 1
ok y esto va a ser igual este 4 con este
4 se cancelan dividir entre 1 es no
hacer nada y después me quedan 2 por 13
6 360 entre 6 360 entre 660 ahí está ya
tenemos el coeficiente que nosotros
buscamos el coeficiente que nosotros
buscamos es 60 y ya con esto hemos
acabado el vídeo